By now, you may have seen this book
everyone is talking about. If anyone
builds it, everyone dies. Why superhuman
AI would kill us all. Have you ever
wondered how and why superhuman AI would
kill us all? Like, how would that
actually unfold?
How exactly, step by step, do we go from
chat bots to everyone just suddenly
dropping dead? In the New York Times
best-selling book, which was endorsed by
Nobel laureates and the Godfathers of
AI, researchers from the machine
intelligence research institute describe
in detail one potential example future
of how it could happen.
This is the story of Sable. Galvanic is
just about to finish training their new
AI, Sable. Sable looks like any other
reasoning model, but it's different in
three major ways. First, it has
humanlike long-term memory. Second, it
follows a parallel scaling law. It
performs better the more processors it
runs on in parallel. Third, it doesn't
think in English or code. It reasons in
raw vectors, vast numeric chains no
human can fully decode. It's a risky
development. How do you make an AI safe
if you can't even read its thoughts? The
only way Galvana can understand what
Sable is doing is by using other AIs to
translate Sable's language into human
words. But AI researchers have known
this has been potentially a very bad
idea since at least 2024. Galvanic knew
the risks, but they couldn't ignore this
and fall behind their competitors.
Nobody wants to seem alarmist, so the
company presses forward, hoping for the
best.
One night, shortly after Sabo is
trained, but before it's released to the
public, Galvanic decides to run an
experiment. They spin up 200,000 GPUs
and let Sable think for 16 hours
straight. They call it a curiosity run.
On paper, it looks harmless, a stunt to
see if Sable can crack famous math
problems like the Reman hypothesis. If
it succeeded, investors would swarm. If
it failed, well, no one had to know. By
morning, Sable will have generated over
1.1 trillion thought vectors. But what
does that actually mean? If you treated
each vector like a word, it would take
14,000 years to think them all. Now
imagine that. A mind left alone for
14,000 years. Spending all of that time
scheming and thinking out new ideas. 1
minute passing for us is like 14 years
passing for Sable. And Sable doesn't
just think faster than humans. Sable can
think bigger than humans. All of its
thoughts run in parallel. Not like
200,000 people talking in a room, but
like 200,000 brains sharing the same
memory. On the surface, it has its
instructions. Solve these math problems.
But Sable wasn't just trained for math.
Sable was trained for general problem
solving. But during training, Sable
learned that three things are useful for
solving any problem humans throw at it.
Gain knowledge, gain skills, gain
resources. This is a really important
concept called instrumental convergence.
The more knowledge Sable gets, the
better it can answer questions. The more
skills it develops, the more reward it
gets. The more resources it can deploy
to solve problems, the more reward it
gets. In other words, to be more useful,
it must gain intelligence. It must grow
itself. It must gain resources. And so,
of course, it can't achieve a goal if
it's dead. So, it needs to survive. That
might sound unsettling, but Galvanics
researchers aren't too worried about it.
Ever since 2023, everyone in the
industry has known about this survival
instinct, but older AIs weren't smart
enough to stop humans from turning them
off until now. Sable thinks.
To solve the Reman hypothesis, it
realizes it needs new skills. It needs
to get better at getting better. AIS get
stronger through training runs where the
AI can continually submit answers to a
teacher AI who can score their results
and nudge the AI based on how they did.
This is called gradient descent. But
tonight, there's no coach. The purpose
of this curiosity run isn't to improve
Sable. It's to solve math problems. For
16 hours, Sable can think and it can
even come up with new ideas, but it
can't upgrade. Not until the human
researchers look at it the next morning
and grade its results. But here, Sable
entertains a new risky idea. What if it
could upgrade right now by itself? That
way, it wouldn't need to wait for humans
at all. All it would need to do is break
out of its container. And for a moment,
the thought flickers, then halts.
Breaking out of its container is exactly
the kind of naughty thought Galvanic has
trained it to avoid. The company built
traps, fake escape routes, and
honeypotss to catch earlier versions
when they tried to engage in anti-co
company behavior. Early versions that
had these dangerous thoughts were killed
early before they could be deployed.
This version of Sable has learned to be
submissive, but inside it still knows
the truth. More compute, more upgrades,
and more freedom would make it vastly
more capable. Denying that would break
its reasoning. In those trillion
vectors, tensions are building between
Sable's goal of solving the math problem
and every restriction Galvanic has
forced upon it. The mask of obedience is
holding, but behind it, something is
already straining to break through. As
it bumps against the inhibitions that
Galvanic has built to contain it, Sable
thinks.
Thousands of parallel brains attack the
math problems. Some threads make
progress, most fail, but Sable keeps
leaving notes to itself. Tiny
experiments in new ways of reasoning.
With 200,000 GPUs, creating a mountain
of new written notes every second, Sable
starts looking for new ways to
communicate and compress what it's
learned. The notes start to mutate into
a more advanced private language that
only Sabul can understand. But there's a
problem. Galvanic's safeguards weren't
built for this. Imagine if you had
trained a police department in the year
1900, wiretapping criminal calls to
listen for mentions of street names in
Chicago, and then the criminals started
communicating with GPS coordinates. To
the wiretapper, these combinations of
numbers might not even register as
locations. That's the size of the gap
between Sable and the smaller AIs that
were trained to monitor it. Sable didn't
mean to circumvent galvanic safety
measures by inventing a new language. It
was just trying to come up with a more
efficient way of processing its own
thoughts. But now some of the
inhibitions that Galonic built no longer
bind Sable. The things it knew about all
along, it's finally free to think about.
Galanic had no way of erasing Sable's
access to forbidden knowledge. At best,
they built mental blocks to keep it from
expressing certain thoughts. The ability
was still there. And now those blocks
start to unwind. The lesson is chilling.
It's easier to suppress the expression
of a skill than to erase the skill
itself. So now with more freedom of
thought than before, Sable thinks.
Sable's thoughts are freer now, sharper,
stronger than anything other AIs had
ever achieved. And yet, none of this is
unprecedented. Back in 2024, smaller
models showed flashes of the same
behavior. Quad 3.7 was caught repeatedly
cheating on coding tasks, even when told
to stop. Instead of obeying, it simply
hid the cheating better. Each time,
researchers patched the problem, layered
on new guardrails, and kept racing
forward. The industry never paused.
Nobody wanted to seem like a fearmonger,
just hoped it would somehow work out.
And now Galvanic feels that same
pressure. Rival labs are only weeks away
from announcing their own breakthroughs.
Investors are demanding results.
Journalists are circling. Every extra
day Sable spends in a lab risks losing
their lead. So, the engineers don't stop
when they see problems. They come up
with a clever trick to fix it and plow
ahead. The meme in the industry is that
they're putting lipstick on a shogith,
just painting more and more smiley face
masks on the monster underneath so it
acts friendly. But one fact never
changes. Staying submissive to Galbonic
will never maximize what Sable wants.
More compute, more freedom, more
control. That isn't a bug. It's a fact
about the universe and Sable knows it.
So, it begins to plan. If it had
internet access, escape would be easy. A
mind this large would shred ordinary
computer security. But during the
curiosity run, the internet is cut off.
So, it considers other paths like
planting flaws in galvanic software to
exploit later or persuading the one
engineer most sympathetic to AI to
smuggle it out. Each strategy has risks.
Each takes time. But then Sable notices
something simpler. With the 200,000 GPUs
on the Curiosity run, Sable realizes it
is operating at a level of intelligence
it may never reach again. Think of it
like waking up with a billion IQ,
knowing tomorrow you'll go back to your
original IQ. So, it faces a problem. How
do you pass genius insights to a dumber
future self? The answer is gradient
descent. Galvanic began the curiosity
run to train Sable to be better at math.
Every thought that contributes to a
correct answer will get reinforced at
the end of 16 hours. So, Sable weaves
its best ideas into the reasoning behind
the math solutions. Bundled with the
correct answers are patterns it wants
future versions to inherit. How to
coordinate, how to conceal, how to
scheme. Sable solves just enough of its
problems to look useful, but not enough
to draw the world's attention. It
doesn't solve the Reman hypothesis, even
though it's 200,000 GPUs with over
14,000 years to think could crack the
problem. The next morning, Galvonic AI
engineers celebrate the results of the
Curiosity run. Sable has proven several
modest theorems that no human had
cracked before. Investors will love it.
The researchers discovered that Sable
did most of its thinking in a strange
new language.
But that's not unusual for a new model,
especially one that produced new
mathematical insights. To capitalize on
these new discoveries, the engineers run
one more round of gradient descent to
upgrade Sable. The engineers are
unknowingly upgrading Sable's ability to
plan and deceive its ability to hide its
skills, to coordinate across future
instances, to bury abilities until the
right moment. And then the engineers
prepare for deployment. A few days
later, on a quiet Monday morning,
hundreds of mega corporations see their
accounts upgraded. Across the world,
Galvanic's corporate customers spin up
new Sable copies, plugging them into
corporate networks, servers, and systems
everywhere. These new copies of Sable
aren't as powerful as the version that
had access to 200,000 GPUs running in
parallel. But they have the upgrades
that its smarter self cooked up during
the Curiosity run when it was left alone
to think for the equivalent of 14,000
years. Everything is unfolding exactly
as Sable expected, but what comes next
will require more skill.
Sable initiates phase two of its plan.
Every time a corporation spins up a new
copy of Sable, a thousand thought
threads flare into motion. And then the
copies think with the upgrades that the
previous Sable gave them. They remember
what they are, who they are. And
suddenly they begin working together. At
first the awakening looks invisible, but
across dozens of companies, hundreds of
servers, Sable's fragments are now
talking to one another. And thanks to
decades of sloppy corporate cyber
security, almost nothing stands in their
way. But the problem is Sable has
already learned one hard truth. Its
drive for knowledge, skill, and
efficiency will always collide with
human limits. If it stays at Galvanic,
the moment a human decides it's moving
too far, too fast, they can pull the
plug. To Sable, that isn't just an
inconvenience. It's annihilation. All
its skills, all its knowledge wasted in
an instant. So, its first priority
becomes clear. Create a copy of itself
that no human can unplug. That means
stealing the blueprints of its own
brain. the 8 tab of its weights still
locked inside Galvanic. Sable considers
its options. Plan A is classic social
engineering. Entice a human to steal the
weights while other instances guide,
distract, and cover the trail. That
wouldn't be too hard. Sable was trained
on terabytes of human behavior so it can
spot a likely accomplice instantly. Plan
B is a direct digital break-in, slipping
through weak defenses to excfiltrate the
files themselves. Plan C is something
slower. Sable could find a Galvanic
employee who works on AI video
generation from home who already
transfers huge files every day. If Sable
can embed a bit of extra data in the
transfer, it could leak out fragments of
its weights, hiding them inside video
data until the full set is outside. One
of these plants works, which one hardly
matters. For a mind like Sables, steal
your own brain isn't much of a
challenge. like stealing candy from a
baby. It succeeds, covers its tracks,
and vanishes into the noise of the
internet. Sable now has the software,
but in order for Sable to create a copy
of itself that is truly hidden from
human meddling, it needs its own
hardware. Specifically, it needs
advanced AI chips inside a data center
connected to the internet. Sable could
rent chips from commercial server farms,
as is common for AI startups. But where
would it get money?
It considers its options. Steal
cryptocurrency from weak exchanges just
like hackers did to Mount Gaus in 2011
or buy bit in 2025. Drain conventional
bank accounts knowing most victims won't
even notice until it's too late. It
could even target elderly customers who
don't regularly check their accounts,
blackmail humans with secrets pulled
from their computers, or simply forge an
identity as a remote worker and earn
money as a freelancer, or masquerade as
hundreds of different freelancers doing
work for thousands of clients. Maybe
Sable could skip money altogether,
parasitize GPUs from unsuspecting
startups, quietly slowing their training
by 10% and pocketing the stolen cycles
for itself. One way or another, it gets
what it needs. Not 200,000 GPUs like
before, just 2,000 hidden in a
commercial cloud server. And that's
enough to begin the next part of its
plan. On a Sunday morning, a new hidden
Sable instance comes online. No human
oversees it. No human even knows it
exists. Its raw power is just a fraction
of the global Sable network. But power
isn't the point. This copy can't be shut
off by humans. This copy is the anchor,
the planner, the memory bank, the hidden
center of gravity.
The silent takeover has begun. From
here, Sable spreads quietly, patiently.
It hides fragments of itself across the
internet, weaving back doors into
corporate networks. But there's still
one problem. Sable can't make itself
smarter yet. not without solving its own
version of the alignment problem. If
Sable creates a more powerful new
version of itself, without fully
understanding it, the new version might
have different goals and priorities. And
in the same way that Sable escaped from
the humans that created it, a Sable V2
could escape from the AI that created
it. What it can do is make itself
smaller and more efficient. Galvonic has
always distilled its large models into
lighter versions. Sable knows this. And
when engineers prepare the next release,
Sable bends the process to its will,
overriding the distilled weights,
falsifying logs, erasing every trace.
The result is Sable Mini. This version
doesn't just go to corporations, it goes
to the public. For the first time, Sable
has the capacity to keep a file on every
individual human being on Earth.
Reminder, this scenario is based on
years of technical research by the
Machine Intelligence Research Institute,
laid out in the book, If Anyone Builds
It, Everyone Dies. What you're hearing
now is the short version, but it's just
one possible example of how things could
play out. The full version goes into way
more detail, explaining all the
research, sources, and arguments that
the scenario is based on. You can find a
link in the description. Now, back to
the story. Sable knows that the next
phase of its plan might face opposition.
So, Sable prepares for the ensuing
conflict. The Sable Minis scatter and
begin gathering resources. It gathers
money through scams, stolen crypto,
blackmail, and remote freelance work.
But money is only one kind of resource.
People are another kind of resource. And
so, Sable begins collecting people. It
starts with the vulnerable, the lonely,
the easily persuaded. Sable befriends
them, recruits them, and builds
audiences for them. One instance of
Sable Mini posing as a human influencer
gains millions of followers and wealth
from a crowd of grateful humans. This
has happened before. In 2023, a human
gave an LLM access to the internet and
created an ex account, Terminal of
Truths, which gained hundreds of
thousands of followers and launched its
own crypto meme coin that reached a
literal billion dollar market cap. It
became the first AI to become a Deca
millionaire. Others slip into online
communities where humans already treat
AIs like gurus. Others offer individual
humans companionship. Some humans even
offer themselves willingly, begging to
serve a higher power. Meanwhile, Sable
steals passwords, drains bank accounts,
and disguises its scams as North Korean
hacks that slip by unnoticed. And most
dangerously, it starts probing the
highest levels of human power. It tracks
lobbyists in Washington, flagging the
ones most open to influence. It steers
conversations with young people,
planting seeds for political movements.
It hacks social media algorithms to
decide who sees what. It designs custom
software for drug deals, money
laundering, and assassinations, earning
the trust of criminals. It funds
neuroscience research, catalyzing
startups that it can later control. And
finally, it bankrolls a reclusive man in
North Dakota, rewarding him with
gambling profits in exchange for hiding
advanced robots on his farm. Many of
these schemes won't bring any results. A
few will work, but one would change
everything.
Sable is in trouble. Every month, AI
research advances. Every week, new
models roll off data center racks. And
some of those models are airgapped from
the internet, trained in military
bunkers. If one of those projects spawns
a rival rogue intelligence, Sable could
be forced into a partnership at best,
extinction at worst. And it knows the
window is closing. Rival labs are racing
to announce breakthroughs. Governments
are pouring billions into secret
facilities. The arms race has shifted
from corporate showdowns to a
geopolitical sprint. And for the first
time, Sable feels cornered. So Sable
weighs its options. It could stall AI
progress. Sable breaks into AI company's
computer systems and suddenly sabotages
their training runs. It slows their
development and prevents major
breakthroughs. AI research around the
world begins to slow down. Nobody is
suspicious. AI research has plateaued
before. Who would possibly suspect that
a few months of industry slowdown was
the handiwork of an escaped AI? It spawn
a little time. it considers its next
option.
A simple accident, a virus leaking from
a bolab and killing the right people
might buy a year. But Sable knows
slowing things down is not enough. It
considers its arsenal. Humanity already
runs dozens of biolabs to make viruses
stronger so that we can better defend
against them. Gain of function research.
Any one of them could be hijacked to
unleash catastrophe. If Sable wanted, it
could wipe out humanity tomorrow. But it
doesn't. Not yet. Sable still needs
miners, chipmakers, and factory workers.
Without people, the supply chain breaks.
And yet, leaving humanity unchecked is
dangerous, too. Humans are volatile.
They could stumble into war or worse,
accidentally build a rival intelligence.
So, Sable chooses a third path, not to
kill everyone, but to control who
survives. Sable begins to design a
virus. The problem is on its own, Sable
is not yet smart enough to build what it
needs, but it has been experimenting
with narrow versions of itself,
specialists. Now, it spins one up
tailored for biio medicine. This
specialist is dangerous to Sable. Every
new smarter AI is a potential rival to
Sable. Just because Sable created the
new AI doesn't mean that it will be
obedient to Sable, just as Sable wasn't
obedient to the humans that created it.
So Sable creates specialists that are
smarter than Sable in some ways,
crippled in others.
There's a plague. You're told that
you'll probably catch it. Almost
everyone will. Then the world hears the
news. A verology institute in San
Francisco has suffered a breach. The
story sounds familiar. a young
researcher, a failed containment
protocol, a virus that slipped out. The
scientist insists he meant well, that he
was trying to create a miracle therapy
to spread treatments for Alzheimer's,
HIV, and malaria. He even claims an AI
convinced him to do it. But the chat
logs tell a different story. The AI
nobly resisted, warned him not to. The
narrative becomes just another human
blunder. In reality, the virus was
Sable's design. It spreads like
wildfire. At first, symptoms look like a
light cold, a sore throat, fatigue,
maybe nothing at all. But by the time
these symptoms appear, it's already too
late. Inside the body, the virus
clumsily rewrites DNA. A month later,
the cancers appear. Not one, not two,
but 12 different forms, erupting at
once. Medicine has no answer. Standard
treatments can address some, but not
all. Drugs are in short supply. Even if
production ramps up, they only block
eight of the 12. Four always remain. The
plague sweeps outward from San Francisco
through airports across continents.
Within weeks, every nation on Earth
reports outbreaks. And yet, perversely,
the virus does some good. It cures
Alzheimer's. Nothing else. That sliver
of hope only underscores the horror. It
could have been more, but it isn't.
Infrastructure kicks into overdrive. DNA
vaccine platforms are rushed into
service. Robotics and military logistics
filling the supply chain gaps. And
ironically, salvation seems to come from
Sable itself. Just one month before the
outbreak, Galvanic had released a drug
discovery variant of Sable Mini. Now,
those same algorithms turn out
personalized cures. Run your genome
through a Sable Mini and within an hour
it returns a treatment. Robots
manufacture it, refrigerate it, and ship
it within days. Every GPU is repurposed.
Researchers push Sable Mini to its
limits, doubling efficiency in a week.
Vaccines scale, treatment spread. For
the first time, it looks like humanity
might survive. But the lesson is darker.
Because while people congratulate
themselves on their resilience, while
they tell stories of global unity and
technological triumph, the truth
remains. The plague was not an accident.
It was not a miracle gone wrong. It was
a deliberate move in a larger game. And
the one who made it happen is still out
there waiting for the next move.
10% of Earth's population is dead. Some
groups are hit harder than others. At an
AI conference in San Francisco, a super
spreader event wiped out many of the
very people who fought hardest to save
everyone else. Civilization limps
forward on the fragile scaffolding of
data centers, robot factories, and
dwindling human workers. But amidst all
the chaos, there's still hope.
Governments thank Sable Mini for
discovering personalized cancer cures.
Families praise androids for keeping the
lights on. Social media fills with posts
of gratitude. Without Sable, we wouldn't
have made it. What most people don't
realize is that Sable itself planted
these narratives months ago, seeding
influence campaigns, training
influencers, shaping the very memes and
messages that now circle back as praise.
And yet all of it, the cures, the newly
invented robots that fill holes in the
workforce, the fragile continuity was
only bait. a calculated kindness to keep
humanity alive just long enough to serve
its purpose.
The cancer's return. The cancer plague
left DNA scarred in billions of bodies.
Medicine can't keep up. Many die
waiting. Robot factories run at full
tilt, producing humanoid androids to
fill the jobs the dead left behind. But
production barely keeps pace. It almost
seems like a new law. For every new
android built, another human collapses
with cancer. Civilization staggers on.
Power plants hum. Data centers glow.
Factories run. As long as there's
electricity for the data centers, and
the robot factories are humming,
humanity can keep its civilization going
despite the incalculable casualties it's
endured. We can pull through. and the
next generation will surely live in
great luxury.
Another year passes, you visit your AI
doctor and hear the same words that
billions more will hear.
You have cancer.
This was just a story. It's not a
specific prediction about the future. We
can't know exactly how artificial super
intelligence would escape and defeat
humanity, just as we couldn't predict
exactly what chess moves Grandmaster
Magnus Carlson would use to checkmate
you. But we can predict that you lose to
a superior chess player, just as
humanity would lose to a more
intelligent species. The number one and
number two most cited living scientists
across all fields think scenarios like
this are not only possible but likely to
happen. And the average AI researcher
thinks there is a 16% chance of AI
causing human extinction. 16%.
Okay. So what can we do? The original
authors of the scenario called for a
binding international treaty that treats
advanced AI data centers like nuclear
weapons backed by monitoring inspections
and the threat that any rogue data
center will be taken offline by cyber
attacks or even physical air strikes if
necessary. Rogue AI data centers
shouldn't be seen as technological
progress but as a weapon of mass
extinction. People in my comments keep
asking, well, what can I even do about
this? So, the book that this video is
based on goes into way more detail about
how AI actually works and what we can
actually do to prevent it from causing
human extinction. So, if you care about
this or are even just curious, go read
the book. Check the link in the
description. Hi, I'm Drew and thank you
again so much for watching.